[Musique]
le départ groupé sur longue piste une
vingtaine d'athlètes s'affrontent se
dépassent et but pour chaque centimètre
un nouveau défi pour des patineurs
habitué aux duels un contrôle comment
les athlètes s'adapte-t-il démonstration
avec une étoile montante price la ligne
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour comprendre il faut revenir à la
base la longue piste version classique
une course à deux et de maman c'est dans
les courbes du patineur accélère et non
dans des lignes droites
car se propulser sur la glace présente
des défis bien particulier
le meilleur exemple est au départ le
patin perpendiculaire à la piste
l'athlète pouces directement vers
l'avant la propulsion que efficace à
100% à mesure que la vitesse augmente
langue des coups de patin se referme
[Applaudissements]
dans les sections droite de la piste le
patineur avance à coups de diagonale
il se laisse d'abord glissé en utilisant
sa lame à plat la friction et minier
quand la lame s'incline elles mordent la
glace le patineur peut alors s'y appuyer
et déployer sa force son geste
l'entraînent vers l'autre côté et
l'enchaînement recommence résultat seule
une partie de son énergie est dirigée
vers l'avant
[Applaudissements]
s'échapper du groupe exige donc tout un
effort dans les lignes droites
la plupart restent à l'abri des regards
le bonheur
dicté la cadence les concurrents gardent
leurs forces pour les virages où la
course change de rythme
dans les courbes l'athlète a une bien
meilleure emprise sur la glace d'abord
parce que la force centrifuge l'appui
fermement au sol etc avec les patins
incliné la dame est en permanence sur la
tranche
mieux encore l'athlète ne se dirige pas
droit devant lui
les verts le côté un coup de patin
latéral colle mieux à sa trajectoire
et en sortie de courbe la vitesse est
maximale jusqu'à 60 km/h
[Applaudissements]
mais avec une vingtaine de patineurs la
claque doit restreindre ses mouvements
et observer ses adversaires car un
accrochage peut tout gâcher
la combinaison à d'ailleurs été adapté
pour résister aux coupures
[Applaudissements]
lors des sprints tout le corps et les à
contribution une finale explosive où la
victoire se joue parfois sur une
longueur de papier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]